describe to me how this all works so you
have a thought about Barbie dolls okay
you're writing your stand-up special and
you're looking at Barbie and you go
Barbie doesn't have any nipples and
that's funny to you right that Barbie
doesn't have any nipples just in terms
of like who is making the decisions of
what Barbie's naked body should look
like for our daughters and sons that
play with them right and fully
unattainable waste
and then just huge shiny like just the
meat of the breast just the part that
guys jerk off to
not the life nourishing part of the
nipple that's where it's obscene it is
interesting it's like how you can't see
the nipple in on whatever Twitter
Instagram whatever but you can have like
greased up tits with like suspenders
jamming them down in a vodka bottle in
the middle and that's like fine for our
daughters see that's a that's a good
font though you're right like who's the
guy who made that decision not to put
nips on Barbie yeah was it true that
squirrels can't find 80 of their nuts or
you made that up no if I
find eighty percent of the nuts they
hide 80 of the nuts they collect they
don't know where they put them but then
I realized Howard that's how trees are
planted like God or there is no God but
whatever the [__] the universe or
whatever it is created this
paranoid cokehead animal the things that
everybody wants their [__] acorns
they hide them everywhere and then
they're so [__] up on coke they can
only find like two out of every ten when
you read the squirrel thing you go wait
a second this might be something for my
stand-up honestly I never got sick of
talking about it in my stand-up because
it
it makes me laugh every time it's so
dumb
foreign